also japanese acting and tv shows i
don't know how they are so bad
but i've never seen japanese acting in a
tv show and been like that's fantastic
unless it's like ken watson literally
he's the only one
i feel bad saying that cause i feel like
there's such a broad statement but i've
watched so much japanese tv and all the
drama acting
is appalling yeah it's not it's so bad
yeah especially in like the live action
like especially when a live-action anime
adaptation of a
japanese tv show or japanese anime it's
it's always
it's so weird seeing live-action actors
try to act like anime characters or
doing like the anime style actually
because because you watch like korean
dramas and korean adaptations of stuff
and it's so much better
korea like i watched uh like sweet home
uh the webtoon uh adaptation okay into
netflix and the actors were [ __ ]
amazing in it oh there's a live action
app it's a live action
and the actors are really [ __ ] good
like they're like every single time i've
watched a korean movie or korean drama
i'm always so impressed at how [ __ ]
not not saying that the acting isn't bad
but yeah i just thought for some reason
i'm like oh i've seen japanese acting
it's going to be right
yeah it's going to be over the top
dramatic
all the time it's like i mean i feel
like especially in recent years korean
movies and korean dramas and shows
have just like they're they are like
they are way ahead of like japanese
j-dramas and dream movies i mean there's
so many movies where i'm like [ __ ]
competitive english like [ __ ] something
like some of the like old boy is like i
love that movie
[ __ ] and that's like that's actually
based on a manga did you know
i didn't yeah oh really yeah oh old boy
was originally a manga oh
i got adopted into a korean movie and
like oh that's cool that is that that
movie is like one of my favorite movies
of all time yeah
yeah he's so goddamn good in that movie
i [ __ ] said
photography is fantastic and that's one
of the greatest foreign films of all
time and it's so
you know it's so good you know it's up
there as with like parasites is like
from to me it's one of the best career
korean movies i've seen so i've seen a
lot there are
so many good korean movies right and i
feel like
people are now just figuring out that
man koreans make good movies they make
yeah they're very good yeah
train to busan as well i remember the
first time first time watching train to
busan i was like
i've seen zombie movies i know how this
works and for some reason
it didn't do like on like a you know on
paper it doesn't do that much different
to every other zombie movie but it's
just so
[ __ ] good yeah i i i can't pinpoint
why it was so good
but it's just i don't know what it is
like when i watch japanese tv i feel
like it's like a pantomime
you know what i mean it does feel like
it feels like that level of acting where
it's like
is there somebody behind me i better not
look
and then no it's like
with japanese acting it's it's very
reminiscent to anime
or anime acting which anime acting works
for anime but it doesn't work for
live-action acting at all
yeah well i was asking some friends i'm
like oh i was like because i was
watching with them like
oh are they famous are they famous
they're like oh yeah they're a famous
voice actor
it's like when you're a famous voice
actor you can get roles in tv shows yeah
yeah yeah
it's kind of strange because it's
normally the other way around yeah right
with uh you know western stuff and it's
just odd to think because i feel like
you know as someone who does voice
acting it does not translate to the like
irl like like it's a completely
different skill set
yeah i mean you you understand the
fundamentals of acting
but you know can you hit the mark you
know you're not being told how to walk
you're not being told how to act
physically yeah that's what you do have
to learn that is separate
but there's a lot you don't think about
yeah yeah yeah and
it's interesting i i just wonder why i
sit there and i'm just confused i'm like
why is japanese acting like generally
not as good and not not saying that
there's no there's zero japanese good
actors you're saying
in general the tv production is pretty
lackluster
i think maybe it's because like they
don't really think of like the outs
like outside of japan movie industry as
much of a competition like they might
think it's like because you know
with like you know hollywood films or
like english speaking films right like
you're not only competing with hollywood
but you're competing with literally
every other english-speaking country
right every other english-speaking
production
whereas i feel the japanese film
industry is kind of in its
own bubble but they're kind of just like
no
no for driving force there's no like
driving also like a threat
to make them be like we gotta step up
our game or like or maybe
the fact that like they're probably like
just unaware
right they probably just think like well
you know english-speaking productions
and like other productions that aren't
japanese
do this in this way but for us this
works
with our type of audience so there's no
like they probably don't even think
this is bad acting right yeah i'm sure
people are going to comment be like
there are so many good japanese films
there are a lot of good jobs but it's a
lot rarer to find
a really really good japanese they can't
find a few in between yeah yeah because
especially in like
j i feel like j-dramas holy [ __ ] that's
what i mean that's where you really say
i i feel like i feel like you see the
pinnacle yeah i i feel like the right
way to describe j-dramas from like the
majority i've
watched is just they are very campy yeah
that's right
yeah yeah yeah everything is [ __ ] so
campy and you know there
there's there's an audience for that and
there's like a um you know there's
you know i do enjoy some j dramas but
it's it's it's
less of i think this is a good show and
more just like i i
can just get behind this show you know i
i like i like whatever source material
is adapting
and also i don't frankly i don't give a
[ __ ] about cinematography right
i don't really care too much i'm not
very picky you know well that's good
because j-drama has
zero they shoot it like a [ __ ] like a
daytime tv commercial
why does it look like that like i never
thought i would give a [ __ ] about that
until i watched jade well that's
that's the point you don't give a [ __ ]
about cinematography until you use
something you see something that has no
cinematography yeah
right it's like what are you gonna
[ __ ] advertise me a plunger that does
four in one any second now i'm waiting
for it because how it's shot
it's ridiculous i don't know why it
looks like that it's so weird